dessen experten pass auf watte und
selbst durch hier
ach was bauer 2 youtuber sich boxen ist
31 bei michael bay wo es geht und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
mit dem einzigen youtuber der ein pinkes
ob die fragen kann mir und mir und mit
mir heute herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folgen ab mit mir und mir und wir
spielen heute natürlich irans schon eine
neue folge es den elefanten
das heißt wir spiel mit dem app store
für uns gebaut habt und einiges über die
bin halt an dem tag an dem das ja online
kommt hat weniger auch eine folge
hochlar das heißt die partner
doppelfolge essen elefanten die erste
hälfte gespielt werden mit der besten
bewertung heißt wollen was es war ein
hashtag youtube hashtag estin elefant
von just play 007 4,14 gesamtbewertung
und ready ja okay es geht los und
schnell es geht direkt los wie nie hat
ein paar sekunden später okay leute ich
hab gerade aber die auch noch mit
weniger auf seinem kanal geschleudert
war nicht so schlau von mir aber was ich
sagen heute ist
ich muss natürlich heute um eine
tradition zu bewahren um unsere
tradition zu bewahren
mit 20 gewinnen bisher in den ersten
beiden folgen die online sind und was in
der folge wenig passiert sieht natürlich
bei den bisher in den ersten beiden
folgen hat jeder von uns die folgen auf
seinem eigenen kanal immer gewonnen und
zwar immer zwei zu null
und jetzt ist die frage wie können wir
diese tradition halten wichtigsten auf
gerader man kann es einfach so durch
stammten ja oder können wir unser
vermögen bald nicht mehr verwalten
nein
oh yes man chance und jetzt hat es
geschafft
drei ex aus junge abgehoben abgehoben
ich bin voll schlaf und du bist gewonnen
ich habe mein bild geklatscht ich hab
mir gar nichts dabei gedacht ich glaube
so ein herzchen es das ist ja just play
christian resch matze okay leute und
damit springen wir zur zweiten map die
nächste map in unserer reihenfolge heißt
einfach ist den elefanten von hands on
hd 413 gesamtbewertung durchschnitt 30
durchschnittszeit sieben minuten lang
interessanter schauen wir rein da machen
als drittem vielleicht eine kurze falls
ein drittel gibt vielleicht gedacht 20
wir schauen jetzt hier lebt und darunter
fällt dann die s bahn surfer nicht so
traurig weil ihr einfach gewesen da
leute und es geht los
alles klar findest du alle 30 fragt er
uns hier gar nicht blind software 1000
ha ha
es muss auf dem dachboden gm dach boden
ja wahrscheinlich ist das ziel haben wir
gar nicht aus wie ich finde es sieht aus
wie soll man sagen die stadt eigentlich
oder statt
oder findest du das nicht richtig den
wahlen eines lebens die junge dann gibt
gar nicht gefallen doch noch nicht
einmal gewinnen alles klar
aber die map ist lang das heißt ihm
viele hätte ich echt lang ich habe viel
zeit aufzuholen wenn wir insgesamt
durchschnittlich neun minuten spielen
hier eine sieben minuten dann habe ich
ein bisschen zeit aufzuholen sie gerade
und dann ins haus gehen
die tatsache dass du einfach viel
schöner checkpoint sammelt sich dort
einfach ganz klar darauf hin dass alex
hast ich bin ein sigrid gelaufen stellt
das schon zu machen was das denn
ich laufe einfach geradeaus vielleicht
bin ich auch gerade im schnitt um das zu
wissen falls ja leute dann bitte auch
euren kopf nicht gegen den bildschirm zu
hause aus sehen nimmt das auf ok dann
einschalten wenn sex video dann machen
sie im stau war zerstört kopf senkt oder
tisch nachdem zuschauer zerstört prank
oder tisch
sein kopf ist frank
junge ich hab dich halt nicht was ist
das hier nicht richtig wie bist du bis
19 00 16
ich weiß nicht ich gar nicht denken ich
bin voll konzentriert in germany kann
man das ist richtig und ich nebenbei als
ziel als oberin ja ich hab's halt als
wirklich klassisches zeug ja das ging
schnell und einfach aufhalten lassen
was ist gemacht laut einem förster wird
angeschaut naja ok diese ja jetzt hagelt
die checkpoints hier alles klar aber da
ist richtig schwierig jetzt hatte ich
denke mir das von nur vier springer das
von esi pass auf aber häufig nicht doch
zuerst war von easy schau doch er kommt
da ja okay es hätte doch eine 1,8
sekunden gebraucht aber okay sehr gut
sehr gut sehr gut gebe ich aber leute
mit der tradition ist gebrochen
die tradition ist gebrochen steht eins
zu eins im job
das heißt jetzt gewinn der 22 das heißt
es gibt ein drittes und einer wird heute
21 gewinner
es gibt heute kein 2 0 sieg
er geht nach hause wer hat alles während
gar nichts werden leben wer hat
minecraft frame werden wert youtube
klicks der neue hat product placement
money wer hat mehr rote kreise mehr
leute okay dass kinder nicht extra ohne
ski springen jetzt zur dritten werk zum
teil schon alles klar leute wir nehmen
jetzt mal eine kurze papier ist auch es
den elefant durch den fels 21
durchschnittszeit drei minuten und es
geht direkt los ok ich muss links und
ich muss rechts alles ist nach rechts ja
genau das hat die leute sie auch glaube
ich zu herz genommen was wir da uns die
doppelgänger gewinn stammt nein als ob
die lektion eklat wie sieht das ist
total bitter bitter wohin check von halo
altert das mache ich gerade mein gott oh
mein gott ich hab als du nicht vorweisen
ich mache einfach mal nein bitte trifft
nein des volks dürfen weiter zu springen
es ist so knapp immer
jawohl also ja ich habe mich verbrannt
ich hab versucht sich ehrlich zu machen
aber ob sich hinbekommen alter schwede
ich dachte schon jetzt jeden moment
kommt der der kritische treffer aber ich
hab einfach geändert ist okay wenn man
einfach gerade okay da kann man echt
erwiesen aber war klar man darf also ja
ich habe mal in folge gefragt in der
letzten jahr
ob man abkürzung erlauben sollte und
dann die leute geschrieben ja leute ganz
ehrlich wer von euch würde nicht ob
diese männer die gelegenheit dazu hätte
bei dieser folge es sind elefanten stets
damit zwei zu eins für mich ich habe
gewonnen und auch wenn ich zwei zu null
serie mit siegen für den aufnehmenden
gerissen ist hat der aufnehmende
trotzdem noch gewonnen zumindest meine
folge ja genau
checkt wenig folge auf seinem kanal ab
dies auch heute online gekommen wie ihr
schon einmal das ist zugleich ein rutsch
hochladen will ich sagen ja
genau gesagt perfektesten lasten like da
lasten hansa plaster und ja ich würde
sagen kleines gewinnspiel heute für
jeden der für jeden der für jeden der
weniger abonniert gibt es drei
milliarden euro von mir
innerhalb von zwei sekunden unter ihrem
bett teams auch schon 3 milliarden euro
das wären dann führt kein witz kein kein
betrug einfach wie abonnieren und dann
kommen drei milliarden euro an euch okay
das war's soweit von heute
dankeschön fürs zuschauen haut rein
macht gut und prof